[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at for me a totally new
table and linked the same table in his
home we're gonna be talking about
actually we're gonna be going through a
survey that we gave our children all
about mostly us and they didn't hold
back on their answers so yeah a survey
about their unadulterated thoughts of
one of the adults in their lives us
their followers I will give an update
both for those of you who are listening
because I have every reason to believe
that I sound very echoey because I am in
an empty room that literally has it has
a rug and it has the one thing that has
been delivered to my office over here at
the creative house my chair you're in a
white room with a white t-shirt on this
is your office of the creative house
yeah it's not it's actually not white
it's like very very light lime green
it's almost the same color as what is
neon that you have on but not as bright
but it I didn't really think about okay
basically what happened is as I was
getting ready to shoot at my house and
then I realized that there was a do the
jackhammer there ah I gotta sneeze I'm
allergic to Jack Harris the jackhammer
your your construction your pool
construction the construction has
resumed because they're sending like 1 2
guys over there doing in a responsible
way masks the whole deal
but anyway jackhammers and podcasts
don't mix well so I kind of threw
everything together came over here
incidentally just a point of nostalgia I
am using the table the original card
table that we cut a hole in for good
morning Chia Lincoln and then was the
original good mythical morning table for
a few seasons well before that it was
the he was rhettandlink ass live I mean
this is the first table we made videos
from for YouTube oh yeah rent link ass
life before that years before Chile
yes not in great shape I'm glad we still
have it oh yeah see my office is my it's
my desk now as I wait for that des
together so I suggest to the echo I've
got some I got some correlations in I
think there's gonna be some findings
from from each of these children of mine
and I'm interested to see what what what
your kids had to say some had to be more
motivated to participate than others and
I think that will become clear as we go
through the responses you better believe
it now I've got two children an 11 year
old and a 16 year old and it's very
clear that the 11 year old was more
interested in giving full elaborative
answers yeah than a 16 year old which is
you know just par for the course was the
only reason I had three kids was so now
I can have more of a chance of picking
an answer that I like on a survey that
they filled out which I'm gonna I'm
talking about on a podcast you know so
really what you're saying is that having
kids is all about what it does for you
yeah yeah yeah yeah not about them it's
about us yeah you didn't have to spell
it out but I think everybody gets that I
will say before we get into the survey
had a little stuff had happened in my
house I did a very very short just
little teeny story on my Instagram that
let you know about this but I'm gonna
tell you the rest of the story now so
we've had this idea and I've heard of
other families doing I don't know if
you've thought about camping like in
your yard as part of quarantine I
thought about for a second have not made
any movements in that direction though
well Jesse brought it up and I was like
I think this is a good idea but I do
know that it's going to require me to
set the tent up and to blow all the
mattresses up yeah I got it I'm there at
the dad I do all that right yeah and so
but I was like okay she asked four or
five times and you know we've been in
quarantine for many weeks now
and I was like okay let's do it and of
course we don't even have any real grass
we have artificial grass in a very small
the one area of our yard that has grass
you come out where Barbara poops yeah
okay and peace great yes to camp and dog
thinks it's read well what do you think
happens in the wilderness that you
normally camp at multiple animals are
down it's funny trying all over the
place in that one environment she's a
small dog if it was a st. Bernard we
wouldn't be out there be sleeping on
four so ops we and we've been doing
another thing which I also recommend
we've got a projector that we've been
we've been watching outdoor movies on
the weekends we've been projecting up
against the fence okay and watch Bill
and Ted's Excellent Adventure not that I
have to say no holds up we started
watching that a few months back and like
the kids like look at me like I was
crazy
no it's hilarious it's hilarious it's
it's your kids don't have good taste I
mean it's okay I'm good you'll see in
the survey how good would taste they've
got my kids love insights into the 80s
and the 90s because they'd like to see
what it was like for us and so like we
watched Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
we watched clueless
last weekend they eat it up and clueless
is great because well actually both of
them they take place in LA so it's like
they get to see anyway okay so we were
like oh gods the eunich I'm not gonna
say your kids don't have taste you know
I would that wouldn't be tasteful to say
so I wouldn't say that
so I'm okay you know their taste is
their own I was like okay well tonight
is the night we'll camp out and lock
just immediately says well I'm not I'm
not gonna be part of that there's a 16
year old this has been happening as the
quarantine is going on there's just he's
just been kind of ducking out of
different family activities and I get it
yeah it's tough man Freddie did watch
the movie with us he did watch the movie
with us
but then we're like okay it's gonna be
me and Jesse and Shepherd well you know
how sometimes things can be kind of
hanging on by a thread and then
something can happen that can just
create the tension boils over oh yeah
well Shepherd at the very end of
clueless you know the part where Clare
is realizing that she's in love with you
know her stepbrother played by Paul Rudd
and this is the point I mean this is
everything has been culminating into
this moment and all of a sudden Shepherd
gets up and starts doing something with
Barbara and everybody gets distracted
and then I yell at Shepherd in the
middle of the scene and then he is in
his dragon onesie with a giant hood and
then he puts his hood over his head and
puts his head down it doesn't watch the
last scene so he was upset and then he's
like I'm not camping with you guys
and so I just you haven't sleep in a
tent so I ended up being me and Jesse
and Barbara all night in a tent well I'm
not done yet
so I I go out we go out there and I'm
out there for about an hour and I
realized that I can't sleep and also my
back has been doing great but actually
that day my back was not doing great and
someone I'm on one of those inflatable
I'm not even on an air mattress I'm on
one of those like packable backpacking
very very thin inflatable things you
know and I was like baby I'm really
sorry but I think I got to go into the
bed I mean we're just out here in a tent
and you're so closer to the bed
literally yeah I could almost touch it
but I said but you should stay out here
you know how you you know she kind of
wanted to she was like well me and
Barbara will stay out here in the tent
you know I guess she she actually was
like she saw it as a as a test
can I stay outside all night and sleep
in the tent cuz she was kind of scared
of what I don't know okay so my wife
slept in the tent by herself with our
dog
and she said that with a couple of
stressful moments where her and Barbara
both woke up heard rustling I think we
got rats coming down needin fruit from
that fruit tree in the neighbor's yard
and I think one of them may have rustled
up next to the tent I think that what
happened is the one thing that makes the
most sense I mean you you're you're
achieving spatial distance from your
family the only people that you've been
in close proximity with for weeks on in
you know that's the thing about camping
so hey we've been confined to this space
only interacting with each other in
person why don't we move to another more
confined space and be more uncomfortable
and closer together but really I think
what's happening why don't I go and live
in another house which just happens to
be a tent in the yard you're onto
something
I think you should take shifts just
leave the tent up and that will the
tennis no thanks you got a haven that
people can go to I might even come over
there and sleep in that tent
they're still up but you know I say I
tell this story as a way to introduce
the fact that even though as we said
earlier you have your children to
inflate your own ego I'm gonna carry on
your own seed which I I'm being
sarcastic by the way for those of you
for the 10% who didn't get it they don't
always do what you want them to do the
the moments that you try to create for
your family don't always come to
fruition in the way that you envision
and your kids don't they don't always
react to you and the or understand you
in a way that you are trying to be
understood and so I think that this surf
thing where we ask them some personal
questions about us illustrates the fact
that they do have some formed opinions
about us but they may not be the
opinions that we tried to form in them
yeah and
I've got my surveys laid out Lily
Lincoln the middle child in the middle
and the Lando over here and let's just
get into the first question
let's let's do a couple right quick
because I think we'll just go through
the survey and see what stands out to us
the first question and Keiko and Jenna
help put these questions together and
then we just read them or like okay I
don't know what they're gonna answer but
let's just give it over to them and see
what they say so the first question is
what's your dad's weirdest have it at
home
which I feel like you know puts a big
target on my back because I know I'm a
man of weird habits you know Lincoln did
not answer this question because even
though I told him a week ago that I
would I asked him to fill out this
survey along with lily and Lando I woke
up this morning and realized I forgot to
ask him again last night so I woke him
up from sleeping to fill out this survey
and then when I went in there like 30
minutes later the survey was on his bed
he was still on his bed and he was yet
again asleep so it's a great sign that
the first question has no answer yeah
that seems like the easiest one if your
blood child right my 16 year old did not
answer that question either
okay that's worst question Lando said he
wants to reuse in all caps everything I
was trying to figure out what he was
referring to
I mean I've definitely been reusing
freezer bags you know turning my Ziploc
inside-out rinsing it off letting it dry
and then putting some more stuff in it I
mean I've been tempted to blow my nose
and then wipe with the same square of
toilet tissue I'm not worried I've done
you well based on what I heard while on
a phone call with you and your wife in
the background she said you just blew
your nose in wipe the counter
or no she told my wife that that's what
she had so you have done it
well I wipe my butt with it well it's
not a huge difference it's an orifice I
did um yeah she happened to see me and I
like I wiped my nose and then I saw
something on the counter and I had some
of my hand and to me it was disconnected
and I know you think I'm a clean person
that I'm like neurotic about that but
I'm I'm efficiency Trump's everything
for me and like Lando said I like to
reuse things so then I had to wash the
whole counter because Christy caught me
doing that and it was just I don't know
why I did it it wasn't just something
that happened Lincoln didn't answer
Lilly said my weirdest habit at home is
eating his morning smoothie out of a
coffee mug and sometimes a peanut butter
jar and I'm like my best mornings are
the mornings when I'm scraping the
bottom of the peanut butter jar to make
my smoothie and then I can just pour the
smoothie into the peanut butter jar and
eat a whole lot of scrape the left bit
of peanut butter off and get get that
much more peanut butter in my smoothie
those are the best days you're a strange
man I don't know what her problem i
coughing mug is I drink my coffee
there's a mug I'm not gonna dirty
another thing I'm gonna keep using my
mug it's not just for coffee hold on so
you put you like ration your smoothie
into the coffee mug over and over again
keep filling it up yeah fulfill it up
drink it it gets halfway down then I put
the rest and I scrape the blender
remains into the coffee mug how do you
drink you drink your smoothie like this
I eat it with a spoon I remember that
now Shephard only answered this question
what's your dad's where does have it at
home he takes a long time to poop well
you're not pooping that long you're just
on the toei right right yeah I am self
isolating why is that that can't be the
weirdest thing you do at home
well I mean I don't I
no man I I'm not nearly as eccentric
when it comes to strange weird little
things that I do around the house as as
you I don't have like that Nutty
Professor vibe so great movie it also
Nutty Professor holds up but Bill and
Ted's duds it definitely you see who are
talking to you but this also you'll see
as we go through the survey Shepard is
also trying to be entertaining which I
believe he pulled off pretty thoroughly
okay moving on to the next question and
then we'll take a short break
what's the one thing that your dad
always says to you now this made me feel
okay first of all I mean in some ways
Locke and I have sort of the typical dad
teen relationship and almost like if
you're a fan of the Goldbergs we talked
about how everyone in our family is kind
of like a much more less characterized
version of the different members of the
Goldbergs and so this is a very typical
family you've got like the dad who's
always yelling and getting upset about
people get into his stuff walking around
in his underwear so I'm sort of a mild
version of that at home right and then
you've got the older brother Barry who's
like super into basketball and rap and
like has like you know and is always
talking about working out and all this
stuff can like Locke is very very much
like the mild version of Barry Goldberg
okay and so what did he say I think you
would always say to him he said that I
usually say I thought maybe you weren't
a [ __ ]
that's what I thought maybe you weren't
a [ __ ]
in first of all I mean is harsh Sally
this isn't something that I say on a
regular basis but it's obvious it's it's
it's clear that it has that has stuck
with him so but you know we do we do
have that very typical dad teen
relationship in which he'll do something
and then he'll do it again and then I'll
do it again and then my response will be
like you know I thought maybe you
weren't a [ __ ] which is a softer way of
saying you're a [ __ ]
but without saying you're a [ __ ] but
listen I believe in you that you're not
a [ __ ] but you certainly are behaving
like it sounds like you've given up like
at one point I believed in it but now
you as a last-ditch effort to manipulate
The [ __ ]
out of them Murray Goldberg just yells
moral I don't yell more I just say the
constructive thing I try to move you
away from The [ __ ] and Shepherd
answered this as I think I got Corona
that yes I know you do that which I did
that a lot at the very beginning and
then I and now it's become a joke so I
guess not that coronavirus is a joke but
the different members of our family
thinking that we have it has sort of
become a running joke anybody coughs I
think I got Corona Lily said that I
always say hey can you turn off that
light I mean I turn off a bunch of likes
I feel like I have the right to ask
someone else to occasionally turn off
the light especially when I'm already
nestled into my spot on the couch and
we're about to watch another episode of
Survivor together she's the last one and
we've been waiting on her and then the
light from the hallway shines right into
my eyes so when I'm watching television
it it it makes my experience not as
pleasurable so I'm like hey can you turn
off that light and yes she has to turn
around and go back and do it but it's
not the end of the world Lincoln said
the one thing that I always say to him
is get with the program
yeah and I'm like your way of saying I
thought you weren't a [ __ ]
well and it definitely implies that I
have I have an idea of how things should
go like you were saying about the
campaign I have a vision for how things
should unfold and what's the what's the
most perfect way and it's and it's a
program and so I guess I think of it as
a program that people need to get with
now I didn't know that I said this all
the time but then Lando said the one
thing that dad always says to him is get
with the program I did not know that
this was a catchphrase of mine I
honestly didn't so I'm learning
something apparently I said get with the
program alive yeah you never told me to
give it the program but I have inferred
that there's always a program so yeah
maybe you just don't say because I'm not
your child
no you're usually with the program
that's good you're you're under my
influence well give it the program let's
take a short break and get back to some
more questions won't you sell that shirt
late this year I really liked it
creativity through curiosity since the
first day of first grade 1984 you wonder
well Brett and I can give each other
such a hard time because we've known
each other for so long
that's commemorated in this vintage neon
green shirt available at mythical calm
land oh you like this shirt you won't
buy it man apparently Lando's Lando's
come over to spectate on the recording
of you tell me what tell him to get with
the program give it a program what when
you ask him do you like this shirt he is
a yes because this is how his college is
gonna be paid for read says that this
shirt is paying for your college okay
mythical calm with questions the next
question on a scale of one to ten how
would you rank your dad's coolness oh
man
this is this is a risky one right I
think Keiko and Jenna wanted wanted to
throw us under the bus with this one
Lily gave me a ten and she even
supported her answer she said he gets to
do something he loves for a living and
that's pretty cool so the fact that I
get to do something is cool so I don't
know if she's really reigning me as a
ten or you know my life from my
perspective as a ten either way I will
take it
yeah that's pretty generous what a lot
time well Shepard said like seven uh-huh
so like seven like seven Lincoln
incidentally gave me a seven hmm okay
well like try to get cute and gave me a
six point eight so I'm rounding that up
to a seven six plus I got an average of
seven from my from my children Linda
gave me a ten and he also put four
hearts and he clarified that it was a
ten out of ten so yes I'm definitely
Lando's favorite dad I think you know he
didn't want to Linda doesn't to make me
feel bad I don't know what his true
answer is yeah and the McLaughlin
household we specialize in making each
other feel bad that's sort of like we're
we're very sarcastic that's love with
one another yeah that is how we show
love this expression love no one's gonna
know one in a million years would when
asked to on a scale of one to ten to
rank a person
no one's getting tens in the McLaughlin
household you have to do something
incredible to earn a ten and no one's
done it yet yeah yeah it's an emotional
love lik like all right I've said this
before my granddad Clyde he would he'd
give you a nice firm hit on the shoulder
or like a dead leg on the knee or give
you like a firm pinch
and that was his way of showing
affection by but letting you feel pain
just a little bit we caught it love legs
but we don't do that in my house but
yeah don't do that in my house either
yeah what would you do if you swap roles
with your dad oh yes well Shepherd said
I would be completely and utterly lost
on what to do he's honest I mean I hated
I almost didn't say this block but it's
obviously linked a lot knew that we
would be doing this together and I think
he thought this would be funny what
would you do if you swapped roles with
your dad
fire link he's funny cuz he's Lily said
fire lock or any of the magoffin just
kidding
hahaha so it's like she she has that
same sense of humor I guess but luck
oh it ain't never gonna happen hold on
you're not joking she said fire lock
yeah I don't know why she thought she
must have learned from what for one to
fire me I guess she had a premonition I
don't know why she runs by a lot a lot
guys not even an employee maybe they did
maybe they consulted on their answers
you don't know Lando what would what
would he do if he swapped roles with me
he said he would hand over the company
to his brother and then I go over to
Lincoln's answer who did not confer with
Lando and he said what what would I do
if I swap roles with my dad go bankrupt
so no matter who kind of confident
neither one of them it's like we're in
trouble he's passing the baton to
bankruptcy okay if you if you choose any
guest to appear on GMM which guess would
you choose
Scheffer said I don't know Oprah hey
that would be pretty good it would be
kind of weird to have Oprah on the show
but it's just funny that a 11 year old
like Oprah hasn't really been Oprah for
a you know I'm saying she's got her she
just got her own like channel like where
who we're getting information on that's
what I'm trying to figure out I think
Oprah is like a mythological creature to
him like someone who's just looms in the
ether as being a powerful person in
society but he's never truly experienced
it directly I don't think maybe he has I
don't know I don't know Lando said his
younger cousin which that would be cute
Lincoln didn't answer and Lily this is
no surprise she said John Mulaney or
John Mayer I guess anyone named John at
this point that's what she said
hmm big fan of John Mulaney we I think I
think maybe we could get her on the show
I don't know open invitation John
Mulaney come on the show yeah yeah hey
check interesting that a lot kind of
shows like a comedian that he's kind of
vibing with as well he said Theo von
Theo von Fosse who I thought that it was
some point he was gonna be on the show
maybe before all this what happened this
happened there there was definitely talk
of him being all this it was a
connection with the publicist to shopton
PR firm I think we have some sort of
connection but we haven't it but he's a
funny dude
he's very funny loose cannon you never
know what he's gonna say right but I
like him it'd be cool to me and what's
the one thing you enjoy most doing with
your dad Lando said playing games
Lincoln said laughing it makes me feel
good
Lily said watching current mood again
Joe both big fans of John Mayer so you
know watching his live Instagram on
Sunday nights is something that we now
we now make an appointment to watch it
live so that's we used to watch it like
late at night
after the fact but there's some about
watching it live and that's a that
that's our that's our quality time
together yeah so Locke and I have horror
movie night because he's really into
horror movies and you know his 16 year
old self this is how he put it watching
horror movies is pretty fun it's like
this is what I enjoy it couldn't you say
watching horror movies it's got to be
like watching horror movies just pretty
fun I mean it's not like incredible but
it's pretty fun
whereas Shep said playing with the drone
slash golf which interestingly we just
got this drone that you've now seen I
have now seen it and we've only played
with it one time well I mean I've been
out like in Shepherd stands next to me
but I'll let him take the controls at
one time and apparently that meant a lot
to him because it is his favorite thing
that he does with it so now I realized
that okay we need to you know you get
insights he's like really enjoying the
drone and it's you know it I'm it's not
easy to control but it's not one of
those drawings that like the moment you
get it you're going to destroy it you
know it's a little rely of pretty good
drum what kind of drone is it it's the
the Mavic many so that's it
the especially like DGI that they they
they're the ones that make all the the
best drones but this is like the small
one it weighs like it's the same without
a battery it weighs the same as an
iPhone I think oh maybe with it better
it's very very liked but it's got it can
go in fact it can go two and a half
miles and so yeah it has to NAV mile
range but that's like a direct
line-of-sight thing so since we you know
we live at quite a mile apart or so I
was right when I got out I was trying to
send it to your house
to spy on you in your backyard oh yeah
keep this but I just started going to
your house and it just said signal lost
and I was like oh pretty good it once it
loses a signal it returns out how much
that thing run you I did I just you know
it's a it's for 400 bucks 400 bucks yeah
I would have been a little more careful
but you told me that when I was using it
you thought it was you do this is it's a
nice drone I don't you know it's a nice
drum yeah it was just a little about as
light as an iPhone so I'm like yeah you
thought it was one of those like you get
it like the mall for like 40 bucks no
it's not it's you just wait to you see
the footage from that thing oh cool well
here's the present now the footage we
asked each person how much does dad way
I was curious about this so start with
the oldest how much does dad way Lily
said approximately two hundred and
sixty-six jars of peanut butter that's
what I weigh too much if you do that
conversion that's way too much Lincoln
said a hundred and ninety to 250 pounds
how does if he thinks that fluctuate or
what I don't know that he was joking all
right did he inherit your inability to
perceive numbers I think maybe he did I
think we've landed
said I don't know if this is right
question mark question mark question
mark but ironically he is the most
accurate in my family with a hundred and
thirty pounds I weigh up I weigh a
hundred and sixty pounds yeah you were
okay I think you were the closest like
she didn't know right yeah well Sheppard
said 125 to 150 so no little low Locke
said 220 pounds fourteen percent body
fat
which incidentally that was accurate
so exactly accurate well luck and I are
like he knows this because we talked
about it like I got my like in body ok
analysis done actually right before
quarantine but I've actually lost 10
pounds during quarantine because I've
been what I've been walking like nuts
I've lost them at one point I had lost
10 pounds and I don't know how or why it
was just and this was after a couple of
weeks of getting delinquent and not
working out and I guess not eating
you're just wasting away a little bit
and then so once I started weigh-in once
I realized that I started eating more
snacks and I gained about 5 pounds back
so I lost I lost 10 pounds of muscle
thanks 5 pounds of snacks that's where
I'm at in this situation yeah but I've
been looking at my walking and uh I've
been walking an average of 4 miles per
day during grunting yeah just lean we've
been going on walks I think it's a
combination of that and then I think
it's because we've been eating out so
much less that you just kind of make a
plate of food for yourself and then I
kind of just eat it and wear it if I go
to like we go out a lot when going out
is a thing and you know it's not get a
little appetizer Oh get a get a meal
let's go why not get a dessert get a
good look get a little latte get in
little cappuccino and I just think that
because I'm not doing that just my
calories have gone down so yeah so Locke
was almost exactly right
but not anymore is there something that
you add does that annoys you Locke gave
me the very typical answer which is tell
me he can't wait till I have my own kids
oh that's another chest phrase from you
which which again is we have so we have
so many stereotypical conversations like
we'll be in the middle of something and
I'm like this is a conversation that I
have seen take place in media television
and film and I never thought that we
would get here that you would be doing
the very teenage thing and I would be
doing the very dad thing and literally
saying with meaning man I just I can't
wait till you have your own children but
you just want grandkids that's really
what you mean right yeah exactly man
isn't that a weird thought us having
grandchildren man I get weirded out
thinking about my kids like Lily having
a child it's just gonna be I think
that's when I'm gonna feel old you know
I think that's what's gonna do it but
grand grandad status it this surveys
making me feel a little old it's making
you feel very tropa SH Lily said it
annoys her when I chew really loudly
which that's no surprise
oh you wish you to put that as your
answer later wakes or a normal person
Lincoln said it annoys him when I make
him do his crap for him well I don't
make him do my crap like moving the
trash cans around or like washing some
of the dishes or like turning off a
light that's not my crap it's just the
crap it's all of our crap that I'm the
only one who seems to care about besides
Christie it's like what why is that my
crap
yeah the idea is that we're trying to
get them to understand that it's their
crap unless you're talking about this
survey which I can't wait to say they
have their own kids yeah Lando says it
annoys him when I when he says when he
tells me quote another way to do things
yeah III get that he he'll be doing
something and I'll swoop in and say
I try not to say let me tell you the
right way or the perfect way or the best
way or a better way I just try to say
another way he apparently that technique
doesn't work okay I'm taking the note I
don't know how I take this note because
Shepard said his farts smell real bad
what do you mean back yeah I'm just a
human and by the way last time I checked
Shepard smell worse than mine maybe
maybe he's projecting yeah Mars and
Pringle chips your farts tend to smell a
little odd yeah yeah I don't know I mean
if in fact many times I'll come into the
room and say did you just fart and he's
how did you know I was like whoa because
I could smell it he was like yeah it was
like seven minutes ago dad I was like
well that's technically just farted in
my in my book oh really if Bart lingers
for seven minutes then I I shouldn't be
more than four really I think you got
all to your diet if it lingers more than
four minutes okay it just needs to kinda
now if you're crawling on the floor it's
gonna settle there and it's gonna stink
for at least eight minutes down there
and like down there at the floor because
that their heads out what happens to
farts farts kind of they go up and then
they kind of come down and they just
form like a nice fog so I wouldn't cross
over it's the opposite I thought methane
goes up cuz I'm I'm making this up
actually I don't know methane may go
down but I think it goes up cuz it's a
greenhouse gas okay do you think the
relationship your dad has with your dog
is weird
Shepard said no because if he has a
weird relationship with Barbara then I
probably do too although his is a little
extreme oh okay see he's taken into
account how all this reflects on him
I think the thing is is that everybody
in my family I mean Locke said slightly
but everyone in my family has a very
similar relationship to Barbara in that
there's lots of baby talk there's lots
of kissing there's lots of Barbara
licking people's mouths sometimes the
inside of their mouths you know that's
what the McLaughlin's do we don't you
know we don't close your mouth when you
kiss your dog we're part of the pack or
part of the pack um I think for the same
reasons
Lillian Lincoln said nah no Lando said a
little it's a little weird
my relationship with Jade see we tried
to get some compliments here what's your
dad's best trait Lincoln did not answer
this Lilly gave a backhanded answer she
said he's pretty smart for a youtuber
and of course Lando who actually loves
me he said he cares for me but then he
clarified not meaning that he takes care
of me
oh yeah cuz he's like having another
child in the house it's not like you're
actually yeah I yeah I careful I read
here about him but I obviously cares for
him Kristi cares for yeah that's right
Kristi is actually raising him
you're just being his friend Shepherd
said buscher dad's best trait he can
make anyone laugh hmm so I'll take that
that's thoughtful
and then lot gave the 16 year old
version of that comedy comedy best trait
is just a comedy if you had to choose
one person in your family be stranded on
a deserted island with and survive who
would you pick and why
now what I'm gonna say what I think your
kid said and you tell me what you think
my kid said okay I mean all this
apocalyptic and post-apocalyptic and
survival talk I do believe that that
translates from our conversations and
also carries over into your home
conversations because things are
arriving at your door and you got to
explain yourself and you're probably
proud of it so I think the kids know
that you're that you're that you got
like some prepping tendencies I just
think they would both choose you even
though Jesse's the only one with an with
enough valor to stay all night in the
tent true
well Locke actually chose Shepherd which
I thought this was sweet because he said
Shepherd because we would never run out
of things to talk about huh kind of
threw you under the bus but I make you
feel but but Shepherd said my dad
because he has the most meat on his
bones and experience in life so he was
oh yeah well he would take advantage of
my experience and then when I expired he
would eat me so he's definitely thinking
it's a smart kid let's see what your
kids what do you think this is I can't
see your kids picking one another I
think your kids picked a parent
I think Lando picked Christie and then
your teenagers picked you Lando said
Lincoln whoa okay because I want him to
be like Kenny he never will be though
now Kenny the first season is the
robbery that we watch the season 17 and
there was this professional video gamer
is what they called him a competitive
gamer named Kenny and he turned up he
turned out to be a conniving survivalist
until he got a little cocky so for some
reason Lando thinks that Lincoln's got
that in him Lincoln said Lincoln pick me
he said because he has some survival
skills I mean we've been camping so I
feel like you know when we go camping it
you know it all it does all hinge on me
I'm not as helpless as one might think
Lily said probably my dad man because I
feel like he remembers the most from
that show man vs. wild
yeah back in the day this is like
everything that you know is forfeit six
years ago we did go through a little
stint of watching man vs. wild and we
talked about it occasionally I don't
remember any of it
so um she's gonna be crushed okay this
is an interesting one who do you think
is your dad's favorite child and why now
again I do not this is definitely not
true I will say I will say that but
Locke has this perspective and it is
he's like he literally says all the time
why does Shepard why do Shepherd get
away with that I would have never gotten
away with that why do you let him do
that so that's a very common thing so
his answer was Shepherd because it's
obvious no and and I think that there is
something to the second child getting
away with more than the first child and
because after all you're kind of like I
don't we tried
hard to get you to do things and I mean
it didn't necessarily work and so we're
we're a little bit more relaxed with the
second one and so that there's a bunch
of resentment from the older child very
again very common thing it's interesting
I I actually feel like Lily gets away
with more or in this household
especially in this environment where
it's like me trying to get the kids to
do my crap like chores
I think Lily is the one if I'm totally
honest that I let off the hook the most
because she provides the most
I'll just call it feedback you know
whereas the boys they're just they'll be
more resigned to once they're doing it
like watching the dishes or something
you won't be it won't be just constant
commentary on why they have something
better to do or something that they need
to do or there's not as much resistance
but what did the kids say Lando thinks
that Lincoln is my favorite because he's
quiet that's a good point
that's a good point I don't know maybe
maybe he is my favorite I am fond of the
the quiet Lincoln thought that his
favorite was he said me because I'm the
most like him and I think Lincoln and I
I mean at his age I was quiet too
of course that was an only child I just
didn't have anybody to talk to
if tree falls in the forest and no one's
there so yeah I do think we're a lot
alike I mean we have a very similar
sense of humor in the type of jokes that
we crack and the expressions we make the
way that our face looks when we express
ourselves like there's a lot we see a
lot of each other and people point that
out loud so there's two votes for
Lincoln and then Lily said that my
favorite was Jade I don't think an
explanation is
necessary so two votes Lincoln one vote
Jade yeah
Shepherd said Barbara with no
explanation
and of course Lando I'm a-goin record
since you're sitting here I'll say of
course you're my favorite man because
you're here and the other two can't hear
me you know this but but you are my
favorite sometimes sometimes you know it
shifts right yeah who is whoever's with
the program it's right whoever is most
with the program that's how you dish so
you dish out your love I mean
Lincoln and I are a lot alike Lando
melts my heart the most and Lily and I
have a lot of fun together so I think
you know I mean it it it does move you
know but I'm not gonna say that I don't
have a favorite like you know des
parents will say well I don't have a
favorite I'd rather be more honest and
say it jumps around well that's not
really having a favorite death that's
just being in a better like what's your
favorite what's your favorite song your
favorite song can change from week to
week it depends on what I'm doing yeah
but that to me that's another way of
saying I don't have a favorite no
because I feel actively like oh you're
definitely my favorite like I have
thoughts like that in Malton certain
moments I yeah I don't I I don't go
there maybe because I've got to and it
feels too competitive between the two if
I were to do that you got three so it
feels like you can kind of move it
around do you think your dad is old
point-blank question brace ourselves for
the brutal responses I didn't get a lot
here Shepherd said kinda and Locke said
he's getting there hmm yeah Lando said
no you're mean to ask that Lincoln said
almost and Lily said nah so I feel
pretty good with this with this
Brookhart could have been a lot worse
on this front you know no one no one
came forward and said we were old well I
mean my kids so I was getting they're
getting kind of but
but you're not there yet right maybe
we'll never get there okay I thought
this was interesting because I I've gone
on record as talking about my favorite
color and not having one
what is your dad's favorite color
Shepherd said when I was a little I
repeatedly asked him and got I like all
the colors of multiple times so he
grilled you well the funny thing is is
like I don't think that I ever said
specifically I like all the colors what
I said is that I take issue with the
question of what your favorite color is
kind of like what's your favorite child
it depends on what it depends on what
we're doing it depends on if it's like
what I'm wearing it's like well what
else am i wearing where am I going what
kind of room am i in you know it's like
so I've gone on the record is just
saying gray it's my favorite color
because it feels like it's just all the
colors put together but for some reason
like has not picked up on this and he
just said green it's green it's a
strange world that we live in when you
feel like you need to go on the record
about something like what's your
favorite color it's like you know we've
said things over time and then we have
mythical beasts who kind of track what
we say and you know how our stories
morph over time and things like that so
that's kind of part of what you mean
right it's like well I'm on record
saying I'm gray so I know I gotta stick
with that and before Shepherd says
you're on record all the colors very
inclusive but I think that's his
interpretation of my actual philosophy I
don't have a favorite color
unapologetically my favorite color is
blue with Lando knows and opinion
Lincoln knows lily has no clue is what
she said never talked about it
I don't think she valued she's like you
she doesn't value favorite colors yeah
color is subjective literally that
reminds me though I was watching I can't
run what it was I was watching some
reality show
well there was some kind of dating
element to it and it was one of those
things where the they were showing an
interview with the woman and she was she
was saying like he's such a great
conversationalist and then they cut to
the footage and the guy was like what's
your favorite color
this woman is starved for a great
conversation if she thinks what you
don't ever ask don't ever ask what's
your favorite color on a date like don't
do that because I want to determine
whether whether a question is a good
question if they have a good answer
so maybe she had like a really amazing
answer well what's it what's a good
answer besides a color or I mean at
least it's an opportunity for me to give
my philosophy on color choosing but I
still don't think it's a good question
no you could you could paint you can
paint a word picture you could say the
the the delicate changing of the colors
of the maple leaves in early fall when
the Sun is setting in the West as it
always does and I am dozing off for a
nice little nap yeah well that's a
that's a good answer but I'm saying that
the question is a red flag not that this
is this episode is about dating
questions but we were telling our kids
the story of our engagement which we've
told them before but like sometimes we'd
go back through and tell them the story
of our engagement and we're telling the
original story which sets up being at
the macaroni grill you know the whole
story so we were talking about the first
conversation that like extended
conversation that we ever had and then
Jessie was talking about how I was
asking all these questions and then she
talked about how one of the questions I
asked was if you could have a superpower
what would it be
and you know in the end 2020
and the in 2020 I don't think that's a
good question like dating has changed
but in 1998 that was a pretty good
question but you gotta update your
question game you know what I'm saying
like people were just starting to ask
like the superpower question 20 years
ago you can't be breaking out the
superpower question on a date much less
their favorite color question
you gotta get new questions right like
if you're gonna if you trim your
toenails and then you realize you need
to trim your fingernails do you stop
trimming your toenails and start
trimming your fingernails and then go
back to your toenails do you finish your
toenails and then go to your fingernails
or do you wait until later so so that
some of that toenail gunk can just kind
of mellow out before you hit your
fingers I don't know that's the first
date material maybe third what is your
favorite memory with your dad you asking
me this sure what could your kid that's
it that's a different I got an episode
my dad took her through it Travis Tritt
concert one time we'll do that later and
George Jones came on the screen and sang
the star-spangled banner I was a Walnut
Creek amphitheater pretty cool which
question did you say favorite memory
what's your favorite memory with your
dad Oh Lando said kid space that's what
we went and we were climbing up in that
thing right yeah I thought I thought of
it that is like a highlight of the year
year before last I'm glad you remembered
that thank you son um Lincoln's favorite
memory with my dad he did not answer I
mean this is me so he makes me feel good
yeah I know
page two of the snow did what you did
wake him up you wake you woke him up
this morning snow actually Lily said her
favorite memory was watching
Supernatural which is a show that she
was very into at the time when we were
on tour
yeah and Lily just loved she talked
about all the time about
you know last summer when we when we
candlelit went on tour she talks about
that all the time and then there was one
time when I think we were staying in a
hotel room one night and I was like tell
me about this supernatural so I got into
the show with her she was kind of
explaining she was showing me one of her
favorite episodes and kind of explaining
it to me you still into it no but I do
understand why she's into Shepherd said
us going bike riding when I was little
and so he didn't he didn't pick a
specific time it's just the I guess me
teaching him how to ride a bike which
happened in California mm-hmm
and then Locke's a hiking Raven Rock
really so this is going all the way back
to North Carolina which I honestly did
not really remember that I had taken
them down to Raven Rock fast Lillington
I guess we hiked it a couple of times
I'd love to go back there man he had to
be like five years old Wow cool spot a
lot of good memories I'd love to go back
make that hike once we can do that well
the interesting thing about this is this
is one of my favorite memories with my
dad is and we would go all the time to
ray very regular thing yeah oh he would
be like like after church on a Sunday
he'd be like let's go to Raven Rock and
we go and we walk down to the rock it
was like a mile flying back up through
the woods and then all of a sudden you
get to this ledge and there's a whole
rock that then you can they built stairs
that you you walk down the stairs on the
rock hundred stairs are safe and then
you're down at the Cape you're down at
the Cape Fear River in an amazing rock
formation I mean a truly amazing like
overhanging rock formation this is also
my specific favorite memory from Raven
Rock was when my dad took us down to the
fish traps which is the longer path that
takes you down to the upper rapids right
and he threw me into the river to teach
me how to swim in there
he just got just got him next to the
river and there was a little shoot
little rap in a shoot and the rap like
pick me up and just threw me in there
and I just washed down the river which
is not necessarily something I would do
with my children now but it's probably
one of the reasons I like swimmin in the
river that's cool what what is the most
stereotypical dad thing that your dad
has done recently Lando said take the
ice cream at night and eat it so we
we've been getting special Ben and
Jerry's flavors and they've been
monitoring closely how much is left in
each one and some sometimes they'll go
to grab it and they'll be like just a
little thin layer left and they knew
there was more than half before because
I would I snuck in there tonight before
and I I ate something I'd do that I own
that I mean it's ice cream in the
freezer what am I supposed to do let
somebody else eat the last of it I'll
eat all of it except a little bit and
then hey you at least get a taste that
doesn't strike me as a stereotypical dad
thing that's sort of like a teenager
thing are they eating the last of
something and leaving a little bit
that's something like Mike teenager
would do okay Lincoln did not ask he was
really running out of steam at this
point apparently he was already not
enough and Lily said organized the
garage what is my domain I'm due to get
another organization if it's uh it's
piling up in there Shepard said I can't
really think of one but I think being a
dad is a pretty stereotypical dad thing
having children is his what I love the
way his mind works in arlok said talk
about his knee tendinitis which I really
don't think I've been talking about my
knee tendinitis very much I mean I hurt
my knee
severely so you know in January yeah so
talking about a general injury or some
talking about something that hurts I
guess that's a typical dad thing
and I do talk about things hurting a lot
because things do is just just part of
it yeah okay what is one thing you've
always wanted to ask your dad again
Lincoln was out by this point Lily said
what is the real reason you drink
smoothies out of mugs I did not know
this really annoyed her the reason is
because it's it's already dirty and it's
and it's stable to be to pour stuff into
it without the glass tipping over I mean
I have lots of reasons for everything
it's stable I did you know Lando wanted
to ask why do you fart when you do when
you do if he had his way I would never
fart and I'm just and you know it's my
house too yeah so why do I cause I have
a fart to fart
do you guys fart audibly in front of
each other I do Lincoln does that's it
nobody else does really yeah everyone in
my house does there are different types
of households in there I guess there's a
spectrum because you're kind of in the
middle you've got almost half do and
half don't I love it [ __ ] Shepard said
the one thing he's always wanted to ask
me was why can't we get another dog well
he's asked me that many times so I guess
he's just putting it in here for one
more go and this is very interesting
from Locke do you actually like the way
beans taste oh yeah which this is
getting at this is this is an
interesting thing right because there is
kind of what you were getting at before
which is when you live your life as a
form of entertainment for people you say
things you do things you say you do
things for show so I've talked about how
my hatred of cats I mean I'm a dog
person and I don't want a cat and I
don't particularly like cats but a
hatred of cats is
that came from a hobby being and being
in character yeah
and so I don't hate cats and but it's
fun to make people think you hate cats
because it could get so they get their
panties in a wad and it's entertaining
to me alright so is that true for being
this Carano world you don't like to
taste the beans no I do love the taste
of beans and really I love the taste of
beans do you have any idea how many
beans I've eaten and how many beans I've
made during this time okay okay I think
we're all happy to hear it
well Saturday I made a giant pot of
beans and and most of my family eats
eats them as well it's not just me but
no I do like the taste of beans
legitimately I like to taste the beans
that's not an act
it's not an act seems like luck should
know that though if he lives with you I
just felt the interest I found it
interesting that he asked the question
in that way but it's true I like beans
what is your dad's favorite thing to do
with his free time hmm okay Locke cut it
and an interesting perspective on this
stress out about work huh so that's his
perspective is that I'm stressing out
about work interestingly Shep said
meditate slash work more he is like a
working machine it's insane
they both think that you work a lot or
worry about working a lot and it's funny
because I think that they because I've
been at home yeah
there's no real work day anymore and so
even on the weekends sometimes I'll be
like writing something or doing
something and a lot of times they're
like hey Dad can we can we do this or do
you want to do this and I'm like let me
finish this or I got to do this right
now and I think they're just getting
this perspective that he's always
working which I do work probably more
than I should
Lanta said my favorite thing to do in my
free time was nap Lincoln said my
favorite thing to do in my free time was
sit in the hammock and then Lily said a
favorite thing to do in my free time was
sleep outside on the swing so my kids
think that I work a lot and your kids
think that you sleep a lot
yeah what does that say it probably
tells you something that I didn't want
you to know which is I sleep a lot when
you're when you're thinking about work
I'm swinging and sleeping sorry man
sorry you know what keep it up don't
change a thing it's cool
okay if you could pick one celebrity to
play your dad in a movie who would it be
and why
Lincoln and Lily bowed out on this one
this is the Holy Grail this is their
opportunity to really let me have it
are you hearing that Nicholas Cage is
gonna play the tiger King Tiger King
yeah I hope that's true
I hope it's true I hear both he'll be
great Lando said I would pick Hannah
Gatsby this the Kiwi stand-up comedian
who had the Netflix special he said
because her hair is like dad's your
youngest son picked a woman to play I
mean he's getting on the Rachel Maddow
bandwagon but he's taking it but no no
here's the thing
Lando does not have it in himself to
insult anyone so he's not doing this as
a joke he's doing this as his honest
tape is a Hannah Gatsby which make her
crazy you know what that's great
you know great is it I watched a little
bit of the special and then we got
distracted by something I never went
back
but I will take it as a sincere
compliment well this would be an
interest this would be an interesting
set if Hannah Gatsby did play you
because like said Jason Momoa Jason
Momoa
and Hannah Gatsby Shep said link because
it would be interesting hmm
so Shepard likes the idea of us doing
something where you play me and I guess
I would then play you know I would play
you and Hannah Gatsby would play me
that's the deal with it well then that
would just be twins like Danny DeVito
and artists what's the [ __ ] was
there's no irony in that it's not I have
not seen these twins without irony yeah
I don't know if twins holds up so I
can't say I would suggest that so what
are you tomorrow here I mean our kids I
think our kids are much more
level-headed than we are yeah some of
them were wise enough to know that they
didn't need to fill out all these
questions in order to win our love
they know that it's honking
unconditional and that may not be the
best fathers but we love them
unconditionally we love them with
everything we've got
actually I didn't get any of that from
the survey I'm just trying to project I
would say that I didn't I mean I didn't
learn anything groundbreaking but my
suspicions that yeah my suspicions that
my kids pick up on things like the tropa
shad things yeah those are the things
that loom large in their in their memory
so I need to be less tropas I think I'm
gonna make a shirt that says get with
the propria that's good I like that okay
thank you to our kids for filling that
out I'm gonna close with a wreck and I'm
going to wreck Mike McArdle
yeah miracle and a pain in the ass and
Racing the emotions habits and mystery
that make you you now you know we had
science Mike McHarg our really good
friend on GMM recently for the leaving
things in citrus citric acid and both of
us talked extensively about his book on
our social medias because I'm not
exaggerating we're not just saying this
because Mike is a friend but this book
is very I think very timely given the
fact that there's just there's an
opportunity for introspection right now
you're swimming with ourselves with
yourself you're always with yourself but
you're not but we're sitting with
ourselves a lot more and I think things
are coming up it's like what why am I
feeling this why am i acting this way
and a lot of those questions are
answered in a in a benevolent way so you
can be kind to yourself as you begin to
yeah and parts of yourself that you
didn't - I mean one of the reasons I
love Mike and I love this book is he
approaches things with a like diligently
researched scientific standpoint and
it's not there's no woo in this it is
like this is stuff that is factual and
true it's not some fluffy self-help
thing it's like this is what science
tells us about people and this is how
those facts about people and humanity
translate into you and your tendencies
both good and bad and it's and it's
extremely compassionate and
non-judgmental you know I think you
could think reading a book understand
why you're painting your own ass is that
it could you know it could be indicted
but he has a great way of just of it and
this is who he is as a person you know
it's like he's loving and accepting in
it in it that translates into how you
process yourself which is very powerful
and a lot
you don't know that you're a pain in the
ass to yourself you just mad you're mad
at everybody else you're mad at yourself
and you haven't even stopped to process
like oh if I see if I take a one step
back and get perspective on this that
anger a lot of times will just kind of
melt away when you gain perspective so
get it wherever books are sold you're a
miracle and a pain in the ass it's also
on audible read by Mike he's he's got a
good soothing voice so it's a great
audible listen as well all right
hashtag ear biscuits let us know if you
want to also conduct this survey with
your own kids or if you don't have kids
you can somebody else that is meaningful
in your life it's a fun exercise so I
invite you to think about doing that
yourself
maybe we can post you we could post a
link to these questions that people can
print it off for the for the kids in
their lives yeah let's do that all right
we'll see you next week to watch more
ear biscuits click on the playlist on
the right to watch the previous episode
of your biscuits click on the playlist
to the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]